attorney Brad Edwards has represented 13
women who accused epstein of abusing
them 12 say they were underage at the
time he's been on their side for more
than 11 years from before Epstein's plea
deal with now secretary Acosta Brad
Edwards good morning thanks for being
here
good morning the government the federal
government prepared a 53 page indictment
against Epstein back 10 years ago 11
years ago but you just heard Alan
Dershowitz say they thought they were
gonna lose the case is he right he's
wrong he knows he's wrong the federal
government had a very strong case they
had identified more than 30 about 34
underage victims the evidence was
overwhelmingly strong so why did they
walk away from that indictment that's
that what we want to know so they went
from in May of 2007 they have a 53 page
indictment literally two months later
there is the exchange of a
non-prosecution agreement between
Epstein's lawyers and the government in
our biggest problem was the victims were
not told anything about it they're
cooperating with the federal government
they believe there's an investigation
going on and meanwhile behind their
backs there's a secret deal happening
between the government and Epstein
that's what was wrong that's so stunning
too rad to hear that you can't imagine
what the victims are thinking well you
can't imagine that does Alex Acosta have
some explaining to do if you ever tried
to reach out and get a conversation with
him during all this time well he has a
lot of explaining to do we filed a case
back in 2008 against the federal
government under the Crime Victims
Rights Act simply saying crime victims
have basic fundamental rights to be
heard at a hearing to confer with the
government to be treated with fairness
I've reached out to mr. Acosta numerous
times formally and informally saying
just sit down with us and explain why
well how many times has he talked to you
never he's never talked to you till
right now even going on television and
sending out tweets it's not helping
anything so he doesn't even say no
comment he just gives you no response
nothing no response I was struck by the
fact that in his statement on Twitter
yesterday Acosta said that Epstein's
crimes are horrific
not alleged crimes crimes are horrific
suggesting he had some sense that he was
guilty at the time or is guilty after
the fact my question is this settlement
this plea deal was approved by the
Justice Department at the time doesn't
that give him some cover here
the deep sigh hi there yeah well that's
because he approved the plea deal what
the Justice Department approved was that
he Alex Acosta could prosecute him yeah
that's what they said
you can prosecute him federally and then
Alex Acosta chose not to prosecute him
federally that's just really what
happened this plea deal was ruled
illegal by a court this year why is it
still in effect we filed that case 11
years ago and fought for 11 years and a
federal judge has finally ruled in our
favor yes the federal government
violated the victims rights now what do
we do about it we say it's pretty simple
it's an illegal agreement between
Jeffrey Epstein on the one hand the
government and the other in violation of
victims rights you invalidate the
agreement but that hasn't happened yet
it hasn't happened yet I would say in
the next six months we're going to have
a ruling on that and I expect it to go
in our favor it just makes common logic
I had other victims come forward since
this story is now back in the news just
in the last 48 hours we've heard from
new victims and one of the main reasons
my clients came up for the hearing who
we still don't know who the new in the
new indictment who the victims are but
my clients from 11 years ago they wanted
to be the hearing they were at the
hearing and it was mainly so that they
can say if there are new victims not
only victims or witnesses they have any
information call us and just just like
what would justice look like for your
victims isn't is it enough that he is
back behind that he is behind bars
there's relief there by your count how
many victims are there well in excess of
50 Wow
that's a big number here's another
question though are there going to be
additional high-profile names attached
to this we have Epstein a lot of people
in Epstein's orbit at the time they
participate what I've personally
investigated this for 11 years and don't
know of any high
file person that would be implicated now
there are plenty of people that are
annotated exactly there are plenty of
people that ran in his circles who have
information and that's one of the things
if you have information you observe
anything you heard anything come and let
us know just tell us what you know this
well many of the high profile victims
are saying they don't know nothing about
nuttin and are now running for the hills
who knew who allegedly knew him very
well that's unfortunate but you're
saying how could you not know
considering his behavior well he wasn't
hiding his behavior you look at the
evidence he's doing it every day
wherever he is and it's not in secret he
had employees that owned their only job
was to recruit girls one women not the
end of the story but the end of this
conversation Brad Edwards thank you very
much thank you very much happy